j'ai une excellente nouvelle un produit
vraiment cool à vous présenter ces sas
et les galaxies les galaxies de bugs
samsung les a gentiment offert à la
suite de l'impact du samsung galaxy s
glisse et dix se disent plus s10e et
franchement je suis hyper dans ce
produit assez petit bugs sont vraiment
top
mais il faut pas les utiliser tout seul
parce que sinon c'est assez moyen
je vais expliquer ça vous à dire
autrement hyper hyper cool et vous me
direz ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire n'est pas qu'un petit
message monsieur grunge encourager des
bugs geiler poste préfère l'airpod je
préfère les galaxies veulent je les
produits de diva corps j'ai les produits
de mode voyage et tout ça voilà vous
marquez tout ça mon commentaire je vous
montre le truc vous allez voir c'est
franchement hyper cool
[Musique]
ça c'est la boîte alors c'est très
classique
c'est sympa gentil design avec le côté
reflet bug c'est joli c'est mignon à
l'intérieur que je vous montre un peu
comment foutu vous avez donc ça qui est
positionné ici et là vous avez hop vous
allez voir rien de bien folichon
violemment lapin un câble usb usb type
c'est pour le recharger et vous avez
différentes tailles pour s'adapter à
différentes morphologies en fonction si
vous avez à des grandes oreilles des
petites oreilles des oreilles de ce que
nous et tous les côtés vous avez de quoi
faire donc ça s'est assez bien c'est
pour la partie boîte
ensuite je m'assis à celui bien samsung
sandby
à cacher parce que oui ça me souviens
racheter à kg il ya quelques années et
aka georges pas si vous connaissez la
cage et des microns qui sont énormes
quand je travaillais en studio il ya
très longtemps d'utiliser des micros à
cacher ou dont j'ai donc complètement
bouffé le nom qu'on mettait vraiment sur
les guitares ça vous donne un grain et
vous retrouver ce sont il ya vraiment
grave et même d'autres fois j'ai tester
des nouveaux casques à kg et vous
retrouver vraiment ce grain est ce son
et c'est vraiment ce qui fait
l'originalité et la couleur de leur peau
qui vous vraiment super ce qui est assez
sympa c'est que lorsque vous leur
changer vous allez avoir une led là qui
va vous indiquer si ces charges et pas
charger ci et ça et ensuite par une clé
d'ici qui vaut 10 6 est rechargée par
charge et comment comment une trêve aux
petits bugs alors on va rentrer dans le
côté un petit peu spec elle votre boîte
vous avez une batterie de 252 millions
perreur donc vouloir charger un gouffre
en gros de recharge de vos petits bugs
et dans vos buzz vous avez des batteries
de 58 milliampères heures bien
évidemment tout ça se recharge en usb
type c vos buzz se connecte en bluetooth
5.0 après d'un point de vue purement
esthétique on n'a pas inventé la poudre
ce qui est assez sympa c'est que vous
n'avez absolument aucun bouton c du
tactile dont vous allez appuyer une fois
deux fois trois fois et je vous
expliquer ce que ça fait là j'ai les
modèles blancs mais il existe en noir et
en jaune pour les voir sur le site de sa
mission c'est franchement cool enfants
n'est pas positif
ils tiennent franchement dans les
oreilles parce que dans ce type de
modèle vous avez à boire et à manger
alors il faut les tourner un peu en fait
regardez vous mettez comme ça voulait
tourner voulait positionner et
franchement c'est cool alors bon après
c'est les buzz ça ressort toujours
toujours assez impressionnant allégée
par la douzième homme petit buzz vous la
mettez vous la tournée un peu
elle est en place c'est franchement cool
alors de tout de suite première
impression c'est que comme on n'est pas
à la différence des raids airpod
l'airpod je voulais poser vous capter le
son extérieur donc vous n'êtes pas fermé
c'est pas le même système c'est pas des
bugs là vous mettez des buzz comme ça
tout de suite ça vous ferme davantage et
ce qui est pas mal mais en tout cas
quand je voyage j'aime bien de faire
n'est donc j'aime bien j'ai un casque
c'est pas du tout celui là c'est un
casque à réduction de bruit de sony
c'est le mark iii
ils vont faire vraiment là ils ferment
c'est pas mal et en plus alors je vais
pas courir under mais je l'essayé et
franchement ça ça tient vachement bien
alors bien évidemment il ya différentes
tailles d'embouts ça détend de la
morphologie de chacun mais je trouve que
déjà d'un point de vue purement
mécanique pour le mettre dans votre
oreille
c'est cool et bien évidemment ça dépend
des formes des oreilles de chacun voilà
ça c'est normal c'est un truc que j'ai
oublié de vous dire c'est que ça
effectivement vous le recharger en une
de l'équipe c'est au point qui est sympa
c'est que vous pouvez recharger
directement sans fil donc vous pouvez
leur charge et bien évidemment sur une
base de recharge sans fil mais également
grâce au samsung galaxy s 10 s10 plus où
vous avez la recharge l'inversé donc
lorsque vous avez plus de jus là dedans
mais votre smartphone encore de
l'autonomie que vous avez encore de la
batterie il ya vous activer dans votre
galaxy s glisse la recherche inversée
vous positionnez vos modes sans votre
smartphone salaires charges et sa grande
force c'est super cool
lorsque vous allez mettre de la musique
que vous allez l'écouter comme ça c'est
un peu médiocre c'est pas mal mais si
vous voulez vraiment profité d'une bonne
expérience audio il faut les utiliser
avec une application et ça change
vraiment toute l'histoire
il vous faut télécharger cette
application galaxie were hebel
mais pas seulement vous cherchez galaxie
bugs et là vous avez galaxie bottes
plugin donc vous téléchargez galaxie
ware et bull galaxie buzz plugin qu'un
petit plugin pour galaxy wearable qui va
vraiment faire la différence dans votre
application vous y retrouver pas mal de
petits paramètres pour vos écouteurs des
astuces
mais surtout ce qui est très important
c'est les quoi liseur je vous le fais un
peu court je vais mettre un morceau de
muse du dernier album
alors je vais pas voulu diffuser parce
que bien évidemment je n'ai absolument
pas les droits de diffuser du muse comme
ça mais ça me permettra de mieux vous
l'illustré le morceau c'est the darkside
là j'avais déjà le morceau sans les co
leaders j'ai un son qui est au final
assez médium j'ai l'impression de
travailler un petit sont un peu tout
fait à peu alors je tourne un peu pour
bien les enfoncer pour essayer de
récupérer un peu de un peu de corps un
peu de basses mais ça reste petit médium
mais si on veut que ça devienne
intéressant et mon avis c'est
complètement indispensable sur ce
produit dans les co leaders jeunes
actives et dynamiques et là ça change
complètement la face de votre sang
lorsque vous l'écoutez comme ça tout
simplement que vous prenez vos petits
bugs vous les mettez dans les oreilles
vous avez en sont qu il ya un peu étroit
moyens pour serrer soit moderne un peu
genre il n'y a pas de corps ça manque de
précision dans les aigus il n'y a pas
trop de médium grave et pas trop de gras
mais les basses en parlons même pas donc
c'est un son qui reste un peu nasillard
et très étroit lorsque vous êtes dans
l'application grâce au plugin vous
mettez les quoi l'isr en dynamique ça
vous élargit le spectre et ça change
vraiment où vous récupérez des aigus qui
sont assez précis qui sont très jolis
médium et qui sont du coup plus valorisé
parce qu'ils sont pas tout seul médium
grave et du grave alors levé les bases
bien évidemment voulait récupérer pas
mais si vous voulez récupérer une
sensation de basses il faut vraiment
bien venir les pousser dans vos oreilles
ou là mécaniquement ça pas vous rajouter
un peu plus de rondeur et c'est là où ça
devient intéressant parce que ces petits
galati bugs tout seul sans l'application
ils valent pas le coup ils sont pas très
intéressant si vous voulez vraiment
profiter complètement de leur potentiel
vous prenez votre appli et vous mettez
les quoi l'isr sur dynamique et
uniquement son dynamique parce que vous
avez notre mode et pourtant ils savent
absolument rien vous allez pouvoir
monter en fait si vous avez dans votre
bande de fréquence ou face en mode
claire est censé vous rajouter plus de
d'aigus médium aigu pour moi ça vous
coupe un peu tout le reste et c'est pas
intéressant alors après il ya en plier
eu franchement on n'est pas vraiment la
différence là dessus parce que ça
développe pas un truc de ouf c'est pas
très intéressant et après vous allez en
dessous plus sur le graphe en dessous
dynamique vous avez léger et ampli basse
ça pour moi ça vous ramène en espèces de
2 médium grave qui est pas beau et vous
perdez tous les aigus pour moi la
qualité audio est vraiment très
surprenante mécaniquement il y est bien
dans les oreilles alors bien évidemment
ça dépendra de la morphologie de chaque
personne
le sont tout seuls non le sont avec les
quadeurs dynamique
oui un grand oui même d'ailleurs et en
si vous avez d'autres fonctionnalités
comme ce sont des petits bugs et
mécaniquement ils viennent obstruer
votre oreille vous êtes forcément peu
plus coupé du son extérieur et je pense
notamment aux personnes qui vont aller
faire du footing en extérieur ça pue un
moment être dangereux lorsque vous
courez en ville donc du coup vous avez
dans votre application un mode qui est
intéressant c'est son environnement
alors moi j'ai désactivé
vous pouvez venir
acte iv et ça va amplifier le son pour
faire simple vous avez des micros là
dessus qu'ils vont dire capter le son
qui vont restituer directement dedans
vous pouvez moduler le volume de son
environnement donc ça va moduler par
rapport à votre musique ou est-ce que
vous allez avoir dans votre casque et
ensuite vous allez pouvoir mettre en
évidence la voix donc jusque là rien de
bien fou mais c'est cool que ce soit
intégrée de vous ça permet d'avoir des
petits buzz qui vont être en pratique
que ce soit pour tout et dans les
transports en commun quand on veut
s'isoler mais également lorsque vous
allez faire du sport à l'extérieur et
que vous avez besoin d'entendre ce qui
se passe dans notre environnement proche
alors autre truc qui est assez
intéressant si vous avez un pavé tactile
vous allez appuyer une fois ces lectures
pose ensuite lorsque vous écoutez de la
musique vous appuyé deux fois ça passe
au morceau suivant
ou alors lorsque vous êtes en
conversation ça va répondre au téléphone
ou ça va raccrocher
ensuite vous allez appuyer trois fois ça
amènera au morceau précédent 1 2 3 op
morceaux d'un an et ensuite appuyé long
et ben ça sera pour refuser en appelle
moi ce sera complètement
personnalisables sont des paramètres
vous allez pouvoir directement
personnalisé dans notre application donc
à la question est ce que ça vaut le coup
d'acheter ces samsung galaxy buzz pour
149 euros franchement je les trouve très
très bien je trouve vraiment excellent
mais pas tout seul si vous êtes tout
seul pour moi vous passez votre route
c'est pas intéressant vous les achetez
et vous les utiliser avec l'application
avec les quoi leader sur dynamique là
vous avez une solution qui est vraiment
optimisé son qualité des aigus qui sont
précis les beaux médium médium grave
vous les enfonce un peu plus le
récupérer à sensation un peu de basses
vous avez un son qui est clair et vous
allez surtout un son qui est équilibré
et avec une signature à cacher c'est un
bon produit et je ne peut franchement
que vous le recommander alors j'en ai
essayé d'autres la concurrence et je
trouve que dans le système de buzz en
intra auriculaires tout faux c'est
vraiment une excellente solution
donc je sais pas vous ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé
ces petits bugs de samsung est ce qu'il
vous le bot alors ils sont aussi entrées
commandes avec le samsung galaxy s 10
s'il vous intéresse je vous ai nier le
lien en bas ou pouilles ailleurs plus
que le s10 c'est vraiment un excellent
smartphone on verra plus tard
le test photo nuit à pas mal de choses à
voir dessus donc ça vous invite à vous
abonner parce qu'on va en reparler
les buzz ils sont cools ils sont beaux
ils tiennent chaud aux oreilles
socratique donc assez bien dites moi ce
que vous en pensez un bon commentaire
est ce que voulait trouver intéressant
oui non quoi comment et puis je vous
invite à les visionner ma playlist qui
doit s'afficher quelque part par là sur
différents objets connectés ou aura
également
aussi parler d'écouteurs de juin trop
auriculaire mais pas que voilà je vous
embrasse
prenez soin de vous à demain ciao